bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regardons
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
vous Jean-François Delfraissy bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous vous présider le
Comité consultatif national des tiques
qui fêtent ces 40 ans ce mois-ci on va y
revenir 40 ans de bioéthique vous y
consacrez un livre les Français vous
connaissent bien depuis la crise
sanitaire professeur de médecine
immunologue on a beaucoup de questions à
vous poser ce soir en particulier sur la
fin de vie alors où le président
consulte à l'approche de la fin des
travaux de la convention citoyenne mais
on commence forcément ce soir par les
retraites c'est la toute dernière ligne
droite avant l'heure de vérité demain à
l'Assemblée la commission mixte
paritaire et parvenu à un accord ce soir
on va y revenir dans le détail suffisant
ou non pour dégager une majorité à
l'Assemblée le 49.3 et dans toutes les
têtes le président réunit la première
ministre ce soir à l'Élysée grand débat
100% politique dans un instant avec nos
invités avant de retrouver
nos affranchis pour leur partiprides
vont vous faire réagir Jean-François
defréci voilà pour le menu ce soir c'est
parti
[Musique]
l'heure de vérité approche sur les
retraites c'est une nouvelle journée
cruciale qui s'est déroulée aujourd'hui
à l'Assemblée la fin du parcours
législatif avec la CMP conclusive
traduction la commission mixte paritaire
a trouvé un accord d'Ivoire contre 4
pour en débattre 4 députés ce soir
bonsoir Louis Marguerite et bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes député
renaissance de Saône-et-Loire bonsoir
Alexandre vincentet député les
républicains du Rhône sur la ligne
marlex Ciotti voilà plutôt alliée du
gouvernement dans cette bataille on va y
revenir bonsoir Kevin mauvieux et
bienvenue député du rassemblement
national de l'Eure et bonsoir Daniel au
Bono député la France insoumise de Paris
merci à tous les quatre de participer à
ce débat en direct Jean-François
delfrecy vous êtes la sagesse sur ce
plateau et vous êtes un citoyen
forcément les retraites vous intéressent
n'hésitez pas à intervenir quand vous le
souhaitez on va commencer par cet accord
conclu par la commission mixte paritaire
il a deux secondes pour nous résumer le
fil de la journée journée le chrono de
Blacko pour démarrer
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir Stéphane bonsoir à vous
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors racontez-nous cette nouvelle
journée cruciale
donc on pense que ça serait peut-être un
petit peu comme au Vatican vous savez ou
conclave les cartes n'ont pas le droit
de sortir avant d'avoir eu un nouveau
pack où il se trouve que la discipline
est un peu plus souple à l'Assemblée
comatican puisque tous les membres de la
commission sont sortis régulièrement
discuter avec la presse en tête les gens
de la nupette puisque minoritaire au
sein de la commission au moins il
pouvait s'exprimer devant les médias
donc leur première impression contre ils
ont découvert le texte qui était des
bâti en commission c'était que les LR
avait fait plier le gouvernement on
écoute Monique Lubin sénatrice
socialiste le gouvernement a quasiment
tout accepté de ce que demander les
républicains pour on l'imagine obtenir
les voies des républicains et ne pas
être obligé de passer par an 49-3 donc
ça c'est la première impression mais bon
le texte fait 110 pages il y a eu 200
modifications par rapport à ce qui avait
été voté au Sénat donc c'est quand même
un petit peu de temps pour rentrer dans
le détail c'est bien ce que regrettait
Arnaud Delaporte PS à propos de
l'article 7 celui qui fixe l'âge légal à
64 ans en écoute
la article 7 une deux trois quatre cinq
six voilà on est à une dizaine de pages
et on nous demande il y a 18
modifications 38 38 pardon 38
modifications et on nous demande de
pouvoir enchaîner comme ça et de parler
des modifications de l'article 7 alors
qu'on nous a remis ce matin ce document
donc on arrive tranquillement à l'heure
du déjeuner cette fois-ci ce sont les
partisans de la réforme qui se disent
ben nous aussi on va aller un peu parler
devant les caméras en l'occurrence
Philippe Vigier moderne qui est
favorable et qui dit qui arrive en
disant bien on a trouvé un accord sur la
question des 43e unités pour les
carrières longues comme le voulait les
LR on écoute c'est très bref
là tous ceux qui ont démarré avant 21
ans feront 43 ans c'est très bref mais
c'est très clair 43 ans pas plus donc
une heure plus tard on se rend compte
que c'est pas si clair en fait donc le
premier à réagir c'est Olivier Faure
avec ses équipes qui pointe le fait que
selon ces calculs il y a bien un tiers
de carrière long qui vont devoir aller
au-delà de la limite stricte des 43 ans
on se renseigne au sein de la commission
auprès des raccords de rapporteurs alors
43 ans ou plus finalement ça sera quand
même un peu plus que 43 ans les
explications du RN Thomas ménager les
républicains de l'Assemblée nationale
sont clairement en train de se faire
enfumer puisqu'il y aura encore des
Français ça a été dit ça a été avoué par
les rapporteurs qu'il y aura des
Français qui travaillent jusqu'à
quasiment 44 de bons travailler 44 à
limiter pour bénéficier du système de
carrière longue 43 annuités et 11 mois
exactement si on prend les effets de
bord et donc c'est c'est absolument ce
que nous nous combattons
oui donc 43 ans et 11 mois oui ça fait
un peu penser au tactique dans les
supermarchés on dit 99 4,99 € pour pas
dire 100 euros là c'est pour pas dire 44
mais changement de l'interprétation du
côté de la nupes on se dit bah
finalement les LR n'ont pas fait plier
le gouvernement c'est le contraire on
écoute ma ville de Mathilde de panot et
Sandrine Rousseau il ferait mieux de
regarder le deal qui sont en train de
passer parce que je pense qu'ils sont
rouler dans la farine et pareil sur le
contrat a duré indéterminée des seniors
c'est pareil ils se font rouler dans la
farine mais enfin visiblement c'est pas
leur sujet bon on les reconnaît à l'aise
dans leur exercice mais ceux dont on
veut avoir la vie maintenant c'est les
LR qu'est-ce qu'ils en pensent les LR
notamment Aurélien pas de pratique était
le plus en point sur la question des 43
années unités on ne l'a pas vu lui mais
il y a des pierres Henri du monde qui
est vraiment un très proche et alors 43
43 11 mois c'est pareil je sais pas
c'est pas très clair les 43 à nuités et
11 mois ça peut commencer à chipoter
semaine par semaine moi après moi je
vous dis on attend de voir le texte de
la CMP regardons l'ensemble de
l'équilibre regardons et prenons le
temps d'analyser
pas trop compris de quel côté il était
mais on se dit qu'il y a quand même un
peu de suspense à ce stade là est-ce que
la CNT va vraiment trouver un accord et
puis là le gag comment appeler ça
autrement un communiqué des républicains
qui tombent autour de 17h qui nous dit
oui on a trouvé un accord avec trois
avancées le problème c'est que cet
accord il annonce alors que la CMP était
encore en train de discuter donc c'est
un boulevard évidemment pour Emmanuel
Bompard et commenter cette petite gaffe
en dit long sur la réalité de cet
exercice c'est à dire que tout le monde
a compris que c'est un truc à huis clos
préparer en amont ils se sont déjà mis
d'accord on a un film qui nous est
déroulé pendant toute la journée mais la
fin du film est déjà connu à l'avance en
réalité bon voilà ça c'est un peu le
langage du battu parce qu'en fait oui
l'accord a été trouvé dix voix pour
quatre contre c'est pas ça je vote
important je crois je crois que le vote
important c'est demain si on verra que
c'est peut-être un peu plus serré que 10
fois contre 4 merci beaucoup Stéphane on
va revenir dans le de l'accord sur les
carrières longues sur ce qui a été prévu
pour les femmes pour les maires de
famille sur le CDI senior mais premier
tour de table vous reconnaissez tous la
légitimité de cette commission
mixparitaire Louis Marguerite oui bien
sûr d'ailleurs comme à chaque fois qu'il
y a eu une lecture nationale une lecture
au Sénat on est dans l'exercice
classique institutionnel avec des
députés dessinateurs qui reprend qui
représentaient chacun et chacune des
forces politiques d'ailleurs le débat
sur le huis clos est un débat quand même
un peu bizarre parce que il y a eu trois
une trentaine de commissions
disparitaires qui sont réunis je crois
depuis le janvier 2022 quelque chose
comme ça elle se déroule tout à huis
clos d'ailleurs il y a eu des comptes
rendus assez largement commenté par les
uns et les autres vous remercier ce soir
les républicains je vous ont permis
aussi de trouver d'accord le sujet c'est
pas de problème
c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est de se
mettre face à nos responsabilités et
demain ça a été reconnu juste à
l'instant ce sera votre important parce
que chacun va être face à son pupitre et
savoir si oui ou non il pense que cette
réforme est d'intérêt général fut-elle
difficile et on pourra revenir sur les
mesures et les mais c'est un vote
important
s'il vote le front en leur ramé
conscience à n'ont pas douter Daniel au
Bono Elisabeth borne dit que l'accord
des parlementaires montre qu'il est
possible de bâtir ensemble des solutions
la démocratie s'est-elle exprimée dans
cette commission mixparitaire non et
encore moins la démocratie parlementaire
parce que je vous rappelle que les 7
députés qui ont siégé l'ont fait sans
aucun mandat de l'Assemblée puisque le
texte n'a pas été adopté à l'Assemblée
et donc en fait d'un côté il y avait un
texte amendé par le Sénat et adopté par
le Sénat et de l'autre il y avait une
page blanche fait là et donc c'est dur
législative prévue par ce qui est prévu
ce qui est prévu c'est que il y ait un
accord sur les deux textes adopter à la
Chambre des députés à la Chambre des
sénateurs donc vous il y a déjà un
risque de forme dès le départ et donc si
la procédure qui a choisi le
gouvernement du 45
mais effectivement c'est le résultat
d'un choix d'une méthode qui passe par
la brutalisation de l'assemblée et y
compris je vous rappelle quand même au
Sénat où il y avait une majorité qui
avait été organisée il a quand même été
au vote bloqué ce qui est quand même
c'est pas une que c'est dur qui se fait
tout le temps surtout que il y avait la
majorité pour le faire donc pour vous
cet accord n'est pas légitime en tout
cas il y a une idée légitimité populaire
qui est claire il y a un vice de forme
parlementaire de notre point de vue
étant donné le fait que il n'y a pas eu
d'adoption en première lecture à
l'Assemblée et que la méthode est
marquée par une brutalité et une
notoriété une notoriété de mauvaise aloi
alors tripatoyage boîte noire des
bagadassées voilà ce qu'on entend dans
les rangs de la nupesse toute la journée
y compris après la publication de cet
accord kevineux est-ce que est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec avec tous ces
mots-là moi je remettrai les choses déjà
dans leur contexte quand j'entends
madame au Bono qui nous dit que il y a
un vice de forme dans le la CMP il n'y a
pas de vis de forme moi je conteste la
façon dont le gouvernement a aborder les
choses avec l'article 47 1 qui a
contraint en termes de durée les débats
et qui fait que même sans vote le texte
légalement peut aller en commission donc
il y a pas de vis le seul vis qu'on a eu
c'est le vice de la nupes qui a voulu
empêcher le vote et au final on se
retrouve sans vote dans l'hémicycle et
avec un vote en CMP qu'on peut contester
ou pas ensuite sur la CMP en elle-même
nous on est on est pour la constitution
donc la CMP on la reconnaît elle est
tout droit ce qui s'y est passé ne nous
plaît pas parce que c'est pas le
résultat qu'on en attendait mais on
reconnaît légitimité du résultat mais la
légitimité du résultat elle est un peu
biaisée par la république bananière
qu'on connaît depuis 48 heures avec un
gouvernement qui appelle des députés
notamment LR en leur mettant la pression
en leur disant qu'il faut impérativement
voter cette réforme alors on a commencé
par les pressions en disant si vous ne
votez pas vous serez exclu et puis après
on a le gouvernement qui appelle et qui
dit si vous votez dans vos
circonscriptions pourra pousser des
dossiers on pourra aider donc on utilise
l'argent des Français parce qu'en
réalité c'est ça qu'il s'agit pour
essayer d'acheter des circonscriptions à
travers leur députés et ça c'est
scandaleux et ce qui s'est passé dans la
CMP aujourd'hui il y a des deals qui
sont passés pour avoir des voix de quel
type de Deal vous avez des infos j'ai
les infos qui sont dans la presse les
excusez-nous de parler aux uns aux
autres enfin pardon juste c'est c'est
aussi c'est scandaleux de dire ça et
quand on s'agit de se battre se battre
pour son territoire moi je me bats y
compris pour des mères qui n'ont jamais
voté pour monter et bien vous avez
raison
vendredi
pas votre voix pour avoir quelque chose
sur le territoire
le gouvernement n'a pas à dire mais
est-ce que vous vous rendez compte de la
gravité de la chose de dire un député
parce que alors j'ai pas de preuve mais
ce sont des témoignages et je fais
confiance aux député qui témoignent si
on si on écoute les témoignages de ces
députés on a quand même un gouvernement
qui dit j'agirai pour être
circonscription si vous votez pour
Alexandre vin pour la République on n'a
pas dû vous appeler vous allez voter
cette réforme
législative en disant que s'il y avait
une réforme des retraites
je voterai cette réforme des retraites
parce qu'elle est nécessaire c'est dans
l'ADN de la droite nous avions en 2022
défendu une réforme des retraites nous
avions en 2017 défendu une retraite une
réforme des retraites c'est nous qui en
2010 avons sauvé le système par
répartition sous la présence de Nicolas
Sarkozy tellement
je sais que vous avez un peu de mal
parfois s'exprimer les autres dans
l'hémicycle mais ici on n'y est pas pour
une fois il y a peut-être pas s'exprimer
et par ailleurs je rappellerai
simplement que moi ce qui me choque un
petit peu quand même et Madame panot a
fait un tweet tout à l'heure dans lequel
honte la CMP n'est pas d'accord avec
nous et ça s'appelle la démocratie des
institutions alors je sais bien que la
France insoumise je sais bien que je
sais bien que la France insoumise la
démocratie ça peut vous déranger parce
que même pour désigner vos dirigeants
c'est la fureur de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui désigne d'ailleurs madame madame
qui sont un mec
la parole vous me laisserez simplement
m'exprimer je dis simplement c'est un
peu facile et je n'ai simplement madame
c'est un peu fatigué
on imposait de vous entendre déjà sur
les positions sur la légitimité au passé
ce cadre là c'est pareil mets-moi madame
monsieur
pour vous dire que moi j'ai défendu une
réforme depuis le début on continue
je l'ai dit mais en réunion publique
on va tous maintenant plonger dans cet
accord qui on l'a compris c'est un peu
jouer à ciel ouvert même si c'est
contraire règlement mais on a eu des
tweets des lives twitch etc c'est c'est
aussi le reflet de la colère sociale
relayée par l'opposition c'est cette
forme inédite de commission mixte
paritaire carrière longue on y vient
qu'avez-vous compris précisément est-ce
que les 43 nuités maximum pour tous ceux
qui bénéficient du dispositif carrière
longue de 16 21 ans sont garantis vous
Marguerite les conclusions et la
synthèse qui nous est qui nous est
indiqué alors il y a apparemment une
contestation de du député fort qui
indiquait que y aurait des cas dans
lequel aurait effectivement il y a un
peu de complexité je sais que c'est pas
très audible qui nous regardent très
important pour les premiers conséquences
c'est comme quand on se souvient du
tableau du Parisien en disant mais
est-ce que ce sera 43-44 on a eu ça et
ça nous a tempéisé l'hémicycle en
réalité ça dépend à quel âge vous
rentrez sur le marché du travail et à
quel âge exactement vous pouvez vous
pouvez donner un premier janvier et
rentrer le travail ce marché de travail
en 1er janvier en moyenne vous êtes
plutôt né en 30 juin vous voyez donc
effectivement
donc la question c'est aussi une
question moyenne donc la conclusion de
la CMP c'est qu'il y a bien une garantie
des 43 ans il faut regarder le texte
précisément pour être sûr que ça se
traduit dans le texte je ne l'ai pas eu
je ne l'ai pas eu alors
que ça se décidera dans les décrets vous
vous allez voter demain mais en fait
vous n'êtes même pas clair sur ce sur
les conséquences de ce pays
pas de problème quand même je vais vous
répondre
entre 20 et 21 ans et c'est quelque
chose qu'on a rajouté alors il y a une
borne d'âge nouvelle à 21 ans pour
bénéficier du dispositif carrière longue
mais là où il y a un loup c'est pas très
clair c'est pas plus de 43 annuités pour
tous les bénéficiaires là c'est pas
complètement verrouillé renvoyé au
décret gouvernementaux suite au texte
déjà il faut comprendre comment
fonctionne notre système de retraite le
système de retraite il fonctionne avec
deux items la durée de cotisation et le
départ d'âge légal d'accord donc c'est
déjà deux choses qui rentrent en compte
et c'est deux paramètres ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
qu'avant la réforme en tout cas vant le
texte qui était en CMP pour quelqu'un
qui commençait très tôt il pouvait
cotiser en fonction de l'âge d'entrée de
sa date de naissance et de la borne
d'âge de sortie il pouvait cotiser
jusqu'à 45 ans d'accord aujourd'hui avec
le texte qui est sorti en CMP quoi qu'il
arrive deux tiers des personnes qui sont
en carrière longue et qui bénéficient de
positifs heureux de façon assurée 43 ans
ensuite ensuite il reste quelques cas
particuliers qui justement en fonction
des différents paramètres la date
d'entrée sur le sur le sur le sur le
marché du travail votre date de
naissance élaborde d'âge peuvent être à
43 ans et quelques mois c'est simplement
que dans vos rangs au sein des 601
députés les républicains et bien tout le
monde de votre a pas cette réforme
contrairement à vous elles amont d'un
gavaba bonsoir vous êtes salle des
quatre colonnes aux côtés d'un frondeur
de la droite Yann Boucard c'est à vous
oui Yann Boucard vous étiez en réunion
de groupes tout à l'heure on le sait
l'ambiance parmi les républicains n'est
pas forcément au beau fixe comment s'est
passé cette réunion très sereine très
claire le président Marleix a expliqué
les avancées qui est plus trop obtenu
lors de la CMP chacun a pu s'exprimer
mais vraiment dans une ambiance dans une
ambiance très sereine c'est vraiment le
bon mot et on a tous convenu que à
vendredi après cette réforme des
retraites ou c'est vrai on a été un peu
désunis durant certains il faudra qu'on
qu'on retravaille tous ensemble parce
qu'on est au sein de ce groupe parce
qu'on a des valeurs en commun alors il
des avancées vous le dites dans cette
CMP pourtant vous demande vous appuierez
sur le bouton contre il faut bien
comprendre qu'à droite on a toujours
défendu pourtant une réforme des
retraites et là vous allez vouloir la
rejeter voter contre demain celle du
gouvernement en désaccord avec le
principe même de cette réforme des
retraites qui est le recul de l'âge
légal de 62 64 ans je pense qu'il
faudrait réforme beaucoup plus
ambitieuse de société notamment pour
redonner du pouvoir d'achat à celles et
ceux qui travaillent en respectant le
travail après je reconnais bien
volontiers que toutes les avancées qui
ont pu être faites pour que cette forme
soit moins injuste sont à l'initiative
des républicains sont grâce à Olivier
Marleix Aurélien Pradet Eric sautier
alors là on vous demande votre avis mais
vous
savez votre groupe qu'en est-il des
équilibres aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
avez pu mesurer à peu près qui allait
voter compte qui allait voter pour et
qui allait s'abstenir si vous voulez
votre des 61 députés les républicains il
faut faire 61 interviews ce soir je sais
que vous êtes très présente au cas de
colonnes donc je vous invite à contacter
tous mes collègues mais vous pensez vous
savez le gouvernement il compte sur vous
pour obtenir une majorité est-ce que ce
soir vous
pensez ils viennent Marleix vont pouvoir
dire au gouvernement de notre côté
réforme pourra passer je sais pas ce que
Eric et Olivier diront au gouvernement
après c'est pas le gouvernement n'a pas
compté sur nous nous sommes la partie
d'opposition qui peut parfois apporter
un appui sur certains textes après
chaque chaque député les républicains
votre ancien âme et conscience en
fonction en fonction de ce qu'il retient
de cette réforme des retraites après le
centre de secrets je crois que le pour
sera majoritaire dans quelle proportion
ça je peux pas vous le dire dernière
question sur ce projet même si chaque
chose en son temps s'il y a une motion
de censure en cas de 49,3 par exemple ou
alors une motion de censure spontanée
est-ce que un vous la signez est-ce que
vous la votez deux choses différentes
une motion de censure spontanée c'est
pas la même chose qu'une motion censure
en cas de 49-3 en cas de 49-3 ça doit
dire que le gouvernement prive les
parlementaires de vote et dans ce cas-là
il y a pas de sujet là-dessus moi je
veux très l'émotion de censure qui nous
serons présentées une notion de censure
spontanée c'est différent parce que si
demain l'Assemblée nationale veut de ce
projet de loi moi je suis un démocrates
respecterai ce ce respecterai ce vote
même si je suis en désaccord avec cette
réforme merci
Alexandre elles sont pas tenues vos
troupes il y a double jeu total au sein
de la droite personne ne suit la
cohérence possible de ce groupe la
cohérence c'est ce qu'on fait depuis des
années je pense j'espère qu'on a tous
soutenu les mêmes candidats en 2022 et
en 2017 quand vous soutenez un candidat
vous soutenez aussi son programme je ne
crois pas qu'à l'époque il y a eu des
voies dissonantes
je l'ai déjà dit il y en a même certains
qui ont signé des amendements d'accord
moi j'étais pas député en 2020 donc je
suis très à l'aise avec ça je suis
député que depuis 2022 mais en 2020 il y
a eu un amendement de groupe
vous n'auriez pas à vous compter à
étaler votre vision
moi je souhaite qu'on puisse voter
demain et je souhaite que demain chacun
prenne ses responsabilités je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que la politique à
mon sens c'est justement être cohérent
être cohérent avec ce qu'on défend
depuis des années et au-delà de ça un
moment c'est assumer parfois des mesures
qui sont un peu populaires sur le moment
mais qui sont nécessaires moi j'ai été
maire d'une ville populaire
Rillieux-la-Pape pendant 8 ans et demi
j'ai dû faire une grande politique de
rénovation urbaine parce que rien
n'avait été fait avant et des moments où
vous devez où vous devez démolir une
tour expliqué à des gens vous allez
démolir leur vie dans lequel ils vivent
depuis 40 ans c'est pas quelque chose de
facile je l'ai fait et pour autant j'ai
été réélu au premier tour en 2020 avec
66% des voix donc les gens sont capables
de comprendre que si c'est nécessaire
même si c'est un populaire vous devez
vous en tant qu'élu avoir le courage de
le faire et je pense sincèrement que les
Français aujourd'hui ils jugent leurs
élus non pas la capacité de lire les
sondages d'opinion mais à la capacité de
prendre les bonnes décisions qu'on sait
nécessaire
mais si on n'aime pas alors on va se
projeter sur le mouvement social parce
que j'aimerais vous entendre là-dessus
puis on reviendra sur le décompte précis
si ça passe ou si c'est ricraque et
qu'on le 49-3 est potentiellement sur la
table il y avait donc une huitième
journée d'action aujourd'hui dans tout
le pays un million 700000 personnes
selon la CGT un peu plus de 400 000
selon la police et un seul mot d'ordre
on ne s'arrêtera pas comme ça parole de
manifestants recueillis dans les
cortèges par Clément Perrot
les deux pieds dans les cortèges mais la
tête un peu déjà au Parlement votre
positif votre négatif 49-3 l'issue est
très attendu par des manifestants un peu
fébril mais qui veulent croire encore un
rejet du texte il y a peut-être des
députés qui pensent
ça va être difficile il y a une
fébrilité en fait personne n'en veut
cette réforme et gouvernement fait
pression même sur ses propres députés
pour les forcer à voter donc il y a une
fenêtre pour lequel texte ne puisse ne
pas être voté vous savez bien que ça va
jouer quelques voix alors qui regarde
qui c'est qui est dans la rue et puis
qu'ils agissent en conséquence
[Musique]
si la réforme passe 49,3 ou pas elle
laissera un goût amer pour de nombreux
manifestants la procédure législative du
texte prête à discussion au point pour
certains dans contester la légitimité
démocratique
de la part de notre gouvernement il voit
bien qu'il est obligé d'aller chercher
des voies d'aller quasiment acheter des
députés en leur proposant de les aider
sur leur territoire enfin on sent bien
que le procédé il est pas démocratique
ni légitime donnant 10 jours ou 15 jours
au parlementaire pour en discuter
c'était impossible quoi quel que soit le
nombre d'amendements déposés ou les
discussions entamées donc c'était le
départ c'était biaisé même en cas
d'adoption du texte les manifestants ne
veulent pas en rester là et compte
poursuivre le mouvement en tête des
cortèges les leaders syndicaux
commencent déjà à penser l'après mais ne
semble pas tous sur la même longueur
d'onde ce projet de loi il est mauvais
donc s'il est voté il restera mauvais
pour la CGT il y a aucune raison
d'arrêter le mouvement au contraire il
faudra l'amplifier parce qu'on aura des
élus qui seront décalage avec ce que
pensent l'opinion publique et avec ce
qui se passe en ce moment dans le pays
si la question c'est est-ce qu'il y a
encore 15 manifs pour finir à 20
personnes qui la réponse est non pour la
CFDT mais il y a d'autres manières de
mobiliser le monde du travail de lui
redonner cette centralité qu'il a eu
pendant ces dernières semaines recours
au Conseil constitutionnel référendum
d'initiative populaire voilà les pistes
que pour réactiver rapidement les
syndicats si le texte est adopté demain
Daniel Bono vous êtes à la fois contre
cette réforme vous avez défilé dans les
cortèges mais vous êtes aussi député si
demain cette réforme est adoptée quelle
que soit le cas de figure 49-3 ou votes
quelle légitimité doit prévaloir la
légitimité démocratique où la légitimité
de la rue et la légitimité de la rue et
démocratique moi je ne crois pas qu'il y
ait une opposition après il y a une
protection en concurrence aujourd'hui il
y a une procédure mais c'est pas la
question c'est quel légitimité
démocratique est-ce qu'il y en a une
purement institutionnelle qui peut
passer par par un acte qui est quand
même 49,3 qui est censé ne pas être
autant utilisé ou ça correspond à ce qui
est très majoritairement dans la
population et je voulais juste préciser
c'est pas un une réaction d'humeur les
Français et les Français savent depuis
des mois ont entendu des explications
ont entendu des démontages
d'explications et en conscience
sans contre cette cette réforme donc
vous et donc c'est quelque chose de
penser et de réfléchir les
manifestations dans la rue les
modélisations les blocages même si le
texte est voté oui parce que de toute
façon la démocratie et l'opposition ne
s'arrêtent pas simplement à au vote d'un
texte on continue à être contre le texte
nous en tant que parlementaire on n'a
pas on a plus d'autres d'autres leviers
pour pour l'exprimer on s'empêchera pas
de le dire et de le redire après le
mouvement social
d'arriver au bras de fer social pour que
même adopter le texte ne soit pas
prodigué des gouvernements y compris des
gouvernements de droite des présidents
de droite et des premiers ministres de
droite qui ne manquaient pas ont compris
aussi qu'on ne pouvait pas gouverner
contre son peuple et que ont eu la
sagesse de se retirer de trouver une
voie de sortie par le haut il y en a il
y en a un certain nombre parce que on je
pense que y compris si les macronistes
pensent obtenir une victoire demain ce
sera une victoire à la Pyrrhus parce que
ce qui s'est passé depuis plusieurs mois
l'intensité de la mobilisation de
l'opposition massive quelle que soit par
ailleurs les
adhésions politiques y compris des gens
qui ont voté par adhésion pour Emmanuel
Macron qui aujourd'hui sont contre cette
réforme tout cela va laisser des traces
il va fragiliser encore plus le lien
entre les citoyens et leur représentants
que ce soit députés ou gouvernement
Marguerite et donc la sagesse politique
et le courage politique craignez pas
aussi de ce de se dire on s'est trompé
sur la méthode et sur le fond et on en
ou on demande au peuple de trancher et
nous on pense que est une solution ou
alors ou alors au milieu des élections
législatives
la question c'est le débouché on se
retire quand il y a plusieurs millions
de personnes dans la rue une colère
existe est-ce que vous craignez gardez
bouché qu'il soit violent c'est
peut-être le seul point que je partage
avec vous c'est vrai qu'il s'est
distendu mais je suis pas sûr que le
spectacle qu'on a offert pendant 15
jours en laissant nationale et
contribuer à renforcer le lien à la
version
et pour nous ça a du sens
à l'Assemblée plein de gens qui ont voté
pour moi ou pas pour moi peu importe ils
ont raison de le dire et vous remarquez
les gens s'intéressent à l'Assemblée
nationale justement c'est la première
action la deuxième raison moi je
respecte moi j'ai reçu à
Montceau-les-Mines dans l'intercy du
bassin minier j'étais très très contre
moi parce que moi je portais cette
réforme je les ai écoutés on s'est
respecté je l'ai même fait mon
initiative mon nom ils ont dit il est où
Marguerite bah j'étais là trois jours
après je l'ai fait voilà ce que ce que
je dis c'est que la question c'est c'est
quoi c'est quoi l'intérêt général moi je
j'ai eu une expérience similaire à
Monsieur à Monsieur vincendais puisque
j'étais pas élu avant et il y a dans une
rayon pique m'a dit je suis prêt à voter
pour vous si vous m'assurez que vous ne
voterez pas la réforme des retraites et
je lui ai dit écoutez moi je pense que
je la mettrai à l'époque on savait pas
si elle allait être 64 ans si ça va on
pensait que ça allait 65 ans et
d'ailleurs c'est un des rares sujets
dont on a parlé pendant la campagne
législative je l'ai invité à ne pas
voter pour moi vous voyez j'étais
honnête je lui ai dit voter pour qui
vous voulez voter blanc si vous le
souhaitez
général
la démocratie parlementaire la
démocratie élective sur la démocratie
sociale je pense que les deux comptes
bien évidemment et d'ailleurs s'il y
avait pas eu tout mouvement social le
texte n'aurait pas autant évolué en
revanche je pense la démocratie
parlementaire elle compte d'ailleurs les
syndicats demain la personne syndicale
se réunit mais attend demain et le vote
ou le 49-3 pour décider de la suite du
mouvement et Laurent Berger sera devant
les grilles de de l'Assemblée nationale
Kevin Maudieu vous vous n'étiez pas dans
les cortèges vous avez soutenu vous avez
fait trois mais pas Marine Le Pen c'est
bon en tout cas pas de banderole
rassemblement national dans les dans les
manifestations c'est un choix que
d'ailleurs vous assumer si c'est voté
demain vous appelez les Français en
colère à rester chez eux pas du tout moi
depuis le début et encore ce week-end
dans circonscription j'ai des personnes
qui sont venues ma permanence et qui
m'ont demandé est-ce que vous pensez que
je dois aller manifester ou pas que
pensez-vous que je dois faire les gens
je leur dis mais si vous n'êtes pas
content manifester c'est votre droit
c'est légitime alors moi je reconnais la
légitimité du Parlement demain si la loi
elle passe et qu'elle est votée
bon bah ça va me déplaire parce que je
suis fondamentalement compte je la
considère injuste un justifié au mauvais
moment
donc depuis le début chercher au fond la
respectabilité et jouer les institutions
vous avez même demandé à l'opposition de
gauche de retirer les amendements là
vous dites quoi ce soir si c'est voté on
respectera le vote véritablement si
c'est voté on respectera le vote parce
que encore une fois on n'est jamais allé
contrôler l'institution en revanche si
c'est voté on ira au Conseil
constitutionnel on mettra l'ensemble des
articles au Conseil constitutionnel on
mettra
la forme de procédure utilisée en jeu
parce que on est on est sûr de nous on
pense que le 47 ans n'avait rien à faire
là et on ira plus loin on dira aux gens
voilà allez manifester continuer à
manifester nous notre rôle c'est de
protester avec les institutions et avec
les outils qui sont les nôtres vous
continuez à manifester parce que ça met
une certaine pression et parce que c'est
votre droit c'est aussi légitime que
nous au Parlement de voter et puis j'ai
envie de dire la façon ultime de
renverser ça c'est l'alternance dans 4
ans Marine Le Pen l'a dit
nous on revient sur cette réforme qu'on
considère injuste un justifié il y a un
moment le rassemblement national qui est
engrange notamment des adhérents pendant
ce temps de la démagogie je vous
expliquais je vous donnais juste un tout
petit exemple en 2010 en 2010 il y a eu
une réforme des retraites François
Hollande avait dit en 2012 et c'est le
modèle absolu du courage en politique si
je suis élu face à Nicolas Sarkozy je
reviendrai sur la réforme des retraites
bizarrement il n'y a pas revenu et la
réforme Sarkozy et bah aujourd'hui elle
a elle avait toujours je finis en 2014
soutenu par l'extrême gauche à l'époque
a même voté la réforme torrent qui a été
beaucoup plus violente qui était
beaucoup plus violent que la réforme
je ne le suis plus j'étais dans
l'extrême gauche et je peux vous assurer
que personne en 2012 vous avez voté
François Hollande en 2012 est-ce que
vous avez voté Jean-Luc Mélenchon et je
n'ai jamais voté que pour aujourd'hui
maintenant par ailleurs
je suis non non absolument pas moi je
n'ai pas voté
les promesses les promesses de gascon en
disant on reviendra plus on est élu
mensonges et ça c'est grossier
vous qui écoutez ce débat avec un léger
sourire et et dans un silence
respectueux est-ce que vous vous trouvez
que cette forme de dialogue de sourd ici
sur ce plateau reflète une profonde
fracture un face à face dans le pays
non moi je pense qu'on est une grande et
belle démocratie et on le dit pas
suffisamment qui a donc des règles
qui sont qui sont inscrites et qu'il
faut qu'elle soit donc respectée alors
j'entends bien les discussions de
certains d'entre vous sur ce qui est en
train de se passer sur les modalités
du vote enfin il y a quand même des il y
a des règles qui sont inscrites je vais
évidemment pas rentrer dans le piège de
rentrer je ne suis pas un politique
juste deux notions
la première c'est que
finalement il y a eu vous le savez il y
a une durée de de
l'allongement de la durée de vie qui est
générale qui est vrai en France qui est
vrai en Europe avec un petit tassement
récent à l'intérieur de ça quand on
regarde il reste de grandes disparités
en France et l'exemple du RER Nord-Sud à
Paris entre
la durée de vie entre sceaux et le 9 3
il y a 9 à 10 ans de différence donc la
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
aux politiques c'est dans notre ADN
français on est toujours avec cette
notion d'égalité d'égalité d'accès aux
soins d'égalité de d'accès à un certain
nombre de grands services publics et la
question qui se pose c'est ce qui nous
faut l'égalité ou est-ce qu'il nous faut
l'équité et l'équité c'est plutôt
d'aller donner et de et de donner plus
aux populations les plus fragiles et les
plus fragilisées pour avoir une réponse
plus globale et ça cette question les
politiques l'on peut plus que notre
modèle français moi le premier toute ma
génération on a construit l'égalité et
que peut-être pour se sortir de ces
questions extrêmement difficiles il faut
aller vers des réponses ciblées et ça
pourrait être le cas le photographe la
question de la justice de la réforme
pour les plus faibles pour ceux qui ont
commencé tôt et qui n'est pas forcément
comprise par les Français aujourd'hui on
le voit dans toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion mais d'abord c'est sans doute
plus l'équité que l'égalité encore qu'il
faudrait regarder dans le détail mais
mais mais je partage cette question elle
est évidemment centrale et c'est ce qui
doit guider notre notre action
je préfère le terme action publique que
politique puisque politique ça peut être
un peu connoté mais peu importe vous
avez raison la réforme va pas régler
toutes les inégalités il y a pas de
doute il y a une inégalité de salaire
entre les hommes et des femmes il faut
là il faut la réduire et il faut qu'on
aille plus loin sur cette question elle
va un peu la réduire même si nos
oppositions considère que c'est pas le
cas la réalité c'est que ça va être un
peu le cas il va y avoir des il y a plus
de droits qui vont être donnés là aussi
on peut conduire on peut dire que c'est
peut-être pas assez mais en tout cas il
y a 5 à 6 milliards de dépenses
supplémentaires de famille notamment
grâce aux républicains il y aura une
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on continue à
faire et encore une fois la loi ne va
pas tout réduire il va y avoir il va y
avoir d'autres projets il faut qu'on
regarde tout bien c'est pas c'est pas
dans les slogans et dans la dans
l'invective qu'on va y arriver c'est
aussi dans dans les cas concrets qui
vont se présenter vous voyez il y a
énormément de cas qui qui nous remonte
et ça peut être parfois des dizaines de
milliers de cas des millions de cas
parfois sur certaines situations donc
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on arrive et tout
ça
64 pour tous c'est ce que vous n'avez
pas au fond manquer l'équité c'est la
question il y a des nuances puisque vous
pouvez partir à 58 à 60 ans etc
absolument et pour des personnes qui
auront eu des villes difficiles par
exemple des des des handicaps etc donc
tout ça évidemment il faut le prendre en
compte est-ce qu'il faut qu'on aille
plus loin sans doute mais est-ce que la
réforme prend en compte un certain
nombre de situations la réponse est oui
alors le 49-3 je voudrais quand même
vous entendre là-dessus parce qu'on
entend dire que voilà si les dégainé on
entre dans une forme de crise politique
que ce serait la fin du quinquennat je
voudrais savoir même si ça n'est pas
forcément l'option qui sera retenue in
finie ce que vous en pensez Olivier
Veyron ce matin au Conseil des ministres
a clairement dit que le 49 ans n'a pas
été évoqué ça veut dire que pour
l'instant Elisabeth borne n'a pas
l'autorisation du Conseil des ministres
pour l'utiliser dans l'hypothèse d'un
vote décidé par le gouvernement
existe-t-il une majorité sur ce texte de
main elle donne mon Agava le
gouvernement fait ses comptes ça peut
passer ou pas et si ça passe à combien
exactement de vous après
bien écoutez Myriam faudrait qu'on
équipe cette salle des quatre colonnes
en boule de cristal en calculatrice ou
bien en jeu de poker beaucoup font le
parallèle avec ce jeu où le bluff compte
beaucoup ce que je peux vous donner ce
sont ces chiffres la majoritable absolue
en ce moment elle est à 287 voix pas 289
puisqu'il y a quatre sièges vacants à
cause d'élections qui ont été invalidés
les députés de la majorité
présidentielle donc René sens modèle et
horizon ils sont 250 il manque donc dans
l'absolu 37 voix sauf qu'évidemment tout
ça se complique puisque avec les
abstentions ça fait baisser le seuil
pour obtenir une majorité alors dans la
majorité justement on semble assez
serein on espère compter les abstentions
sur les doigts d'une main les
récalcitrants seraient rentrés dans le
rang côté opposition nupes RN on sera
100% présence 100% contre le groupe
liotte devrait être très majoritairement
contre l'inconnu vous en avez parlé
c'est le groupe LR on est en train en ce
moment même de refaire les comptes après
une réunion de groupe et après les
conclusions de la CMP si le gouvernement
pense que le texte reste pas ce qu'il
arrive à consolider une majorité avec
les républicains il ira au vote et c'est
plutôt ce qui était dans l'air
aujourd'hui dans la majorité s'il y a un
risque ou si le vote est très serré et
bien le gouvernement peut choisir de le
prendre son risque qui t'a accepté la
défaite soit vous en avez parlé il a une
dernière carte dans son jeu c'est le
49-3 mais ça on le sait ce sera très
difficile à expliquer aux Français aux
oppositions mais même à sa propre
majorité fin du suspense en d'ici moins
de 20 heures et on suivra évidemment
tout cela de près sur LCP des 15 heures
lou Marguerite fébrile ou confiant vous
souhaitez un vote ça le gouvernement la
majorité le répète vous êtes prêts à
prendre le risque du vote vraiment c'est
pas moi qui vais prendre cette décision
elle revient au prison de la République
et sa première ministre Isabelle borne
et au gouvernement ce serait la pire des
solutions pour vous on souhaite qu'un
vote on a toujours dit on souhaite qu'il
y a un vote parce que c'est une question
de responsabilité parce que on peut pas
s'abriter derrière une procédure et
parce que lorsqu'on est face à soi-même
et face à son on sait qu'on est regardé
on est regardé par ceux qui nous ont
fait confiance ce qu'on représente même
si non nous ont pas fait confiance lors
de l'élection et tous les Français et
donc je peux aller au vote si on sait
que ça passe à 10 ou après je pense que
c'est vraiment si c'est il faut qu'on
apprécie les choses honnêtement c'est là
aussi c'est pas moi qui fait des comptes
précisément mais voilà donc c'est très
important le sujet c'est de savoir c'est
très fort mais d'intérêt général ici
dans quelques mois et dans quelques
années on pourra évaluer est-ce qu'on
aura bien fait ce qu'on aurait géré de
façon un bon père de famille notre
régime par répartition le 49-3 acteurs à
la fin du quinquennat la fin du
quinquennat si tentait qu'il est
réellement commencé d'un point de vue
législatif
le 49 3 les lois passent effectivement
on a une dizaine de 49,3 donc elle passe
toutes mais elle ouvrirait une forme de
crise politique évidemment qu'il y aura
une notion de censure mais apparemment
aucune chance d'être adopté politique je
pense que la plupart des oppositions
votre est une motion de censure
transpartiza ou pas mais il y a de
grandes chances que ce soit qui font non
de la tête
de courir non mais les républicains me
font beaucoup rire parce que rappelons
que lors du PLF en fin d'année 2022
quand les premiers 49-3 sont tombés les
premières motions de censure on
entendait les LR sur les plateaux qui
disaient non non on va pas voter la
motion de censure par contre si on nous
si on nous dégaine 49-3 sur une réforme
des retraites en plus dans un PLFSS on
se laissera pas faire bon aujourd'hui
les LR sont infectés par le virus
macronien
LR moi mais faut arrêter avec vos jeux
de posture ça c'est pas une posture
c'est une réalité aussi elle vous fera
un numéro vous êtes en train d'essayer
de faire semblant d'être contre en
disant que vous mettez pour tout 30
secondes à chaque fois vous ne votez pas
la censure c'est une évidence pour vous
bien sûr attendez on a défendu un texte
et des réformes des retraites depuis des
années et sur un texte qu'on a défendu
on irait voté une motion de censure je
pense simplement encore une chose moi
vous savez on va on va voir un choix
difficile
mon collègue de Renaissance a
parfaitement raison de le dire c'est un
choix difficile il faut savoir assumer
l'impopularité du moment c'est en
politique quand je me suis engagé je me
souviens un moment c'est savoir ce que
l'on veut être est-ce qu'on veut être
efficace au service de ces administrés
au service de sa population service de
ses convictions le service de son pays
où est-ce qu'on veut être au service des
sondages je vais vous dire une chose je
préfère je préfère être populaire
maintenant mais que dans 10 ans on ne
gagne pas me dire quand le système sera
par terre parce qu'il sera plus
finançable vous auriez juste et vous ne
l'avez pas fait quand il était temps il
y a je préfère le faire aujourd'hui le
mot de la je vais vous dire mieux je
préférais battu sur mes convictions
parce que je pense avoir fait ce qui
était nécessaire plutôt que de me
planquer et ben voilà on voit vraiment
les camps politiques et une très claire
alliances entre renaissance et la
République 1 sur ce plateau Daniel Bono
à 49-3 quoi aurait des répercussions
dans la rue de toute façon de toute
façon
moi je voulais rappeler simplement que
je crois qu'en définitive en définitive
le dernier mot ça doit être doit être
donné au peuple d'une manière ou d'une
autre et nous nous continuons à dire que
ça doit être il y a une telle opposition
enfin on ne peut pas gouverner contre le
peuple et donc l'enjeu je pense c'est
que il reste une mobilisation il reste
une pression il y a des secteurs qui
sont en grève et pour de bonnes raisons
vous parliez de la question de l'équité
quand vous voyez par exemple les
éboueurs pour qui cette réforme va
signifier deux ans de plus dans des
conditions insupportables le principe
même de notre système pas répartition et
remis en cause par par cette réforme et
donc quel que soit le vote par 49-3
allez le gouvernement a choisi une
procédure qui de toute façon
s'arrête là vous l'avez compris vous
l'avez compris c'est l'heure de vérité
il reste quelques heures on est entré
dans une situation politique des plus
complexe et des plus incertaine
rendez-vous 14h30 demain sur la chaîne
parlementaire pour une grande après-midi
à la fois le vote ou le 49-3 et puis
bien sûr dans Ça vous regarde le soir
même merci beaucoup d'être venu débattre
de cette commission mixte paritaire vous
restez avec moi Jean-François delfresci
dans une dizaine de minutes les parties
pris de nos affranchis elles sont deux
ce soir la carte blanche de Carole
Barjon justement sur la grève des
éboueurs le bal des hypocrites nous
dira-t-elle face aux ordures qui déborde
dans la capitale et puis la féministe
Léa chamboncelle va revenir sur cette
grande enquête mondiale femme à abattre
sur les féminicides politiques mais
d'abord on va s'arrêter Jean-François
delfresci sur le rôle du CCNE le Comité
national consultatif d'éthique que vous
présidez à 40 ans aujourd'hui c'est
François Mitterrand qu'il a installé en
1983 il a beaucoup évolué changer à
mesure des progrès scientifiques de la
médecine mais aussi des attentes de la
société on voit cela dans l'invitation
de Marion Becker et on en parle juste
après
si on vous invite Jean-François
delpressi c'est parce que son célébrés
les 40 ans du Comité consultatif
national des tiques dont vous êtes le
président 40 bougies pour 4 décennies de
bioéthique et de réflexion sur les
conséquences des progrès de la science
l'idée après à la naissance du premier
bébé français conçu par fécondation in
vitro en 1982 François Mitterrand décide
de créer le CCNE il voit le jour en 1983
les nouveaux pouvoirs de la médecine
imposent de nouveaux devoirs les termes
sont indissociables
une réflexion la réflexion
doit être aussi proche que possible de
la découverte scientifique ne pas
arriver trop tard
les questions des progrès de la science
n'appartiennent plus au seul
scientifiques et aux médecins désormais
des juristes des philosophes les cultes
vont donner leur avis poser leur regard
critique sur les problèmes moraux et
éthiques soulevés par la recherche dans
les domaines de la biologie de la santé
et de la médecine
ses 40 ans de bioéthique Jean-François
delfrecy vous les avez retracé avec des
membres du Comité consultatif national
des tics dans un ouvrage car depuis 2016
vous êtes à la tête du CCNE
Jean-François d'alfrecy vous êtes
professeur de médecine spécialisée dans
l'immunologie et spécialiste renommés du
VIH en 2016 vous êtes nommé président du
Comité consultatif national d'éthique en
2020 vous devenez également président du
conseil scientifique sur le covid-19
chargé de conseiller le gouvernement
dans la lutte contre la pandémie
au CCNE vous avez porté le débat sur
l'ouverture de la PMA pour toutes les
femmes en septembre dernier vous avez
rendu un avis sur la fin de vie et
ouvert la porte à une aide active à
mourir sous conditions le CCNE est là
comme une sorte de grande boussole pour
essayer de nous éclairer citoyens
médecins politiques pour des décisions
et dire est-ce qu'il y a des conditions
éthiques qui dans ces situations
extrêmement particulières permettrait
éventuellement et bien d'aller vers une
évolution de la loi dans dans ce sens
une boussole prudente et pourtant le
législateur attend beaucoup de vous
recommandations sur ces thématiques
sensibles tout comme le président
Emmanuel Macron a sollicité votre avis
sur la fin de vie lors d'un dîner la
semaine dernière alors on a une question
pour vous Jean-François delfrecy un
président ou des parlementaires peuvent
réellement s'affranchir de la vie du
Comité consultatif national d'éthique
réponse alors Jean-François d'être
jamais vraiment produit non non mais on
est consultatif c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
fait notre notre force et puis on est là
vraiment comme une boussole pour
éclairer à la fois des décisions
politiques difficiles on l'a fait par
exemple lors du renouvellement de la loi
de bioéthique de 2021 sur des sujets
complexes on a parlé de la procréation
mais il y avait aussi les cellules
souches et on est là pour éclairer le
débat parlementaire et puis on est une
démocratie je le répète et c'est au
politique élu et élue par le peuple de
décider en 40 ans la biologie la
médecine ont énormément évolué on dit
souvent que la science prend de vitesse
l'homme c'est pour prendre le temps un
temps précieux un temps de prudence que
le CCNE est si important
oui là il a je dirais deux fonctions
essentielles qui sont d'ailleurs un peu
contradictoires la première c'est les
avancées de la science moi-même je suis
originaire de ce milieu là c'est à dire
que il a science avance et elle avancera
toujours et tant mieux et c'est ça a été
les progrès extraordinaires la notion de
programme est en train un peu de la
perdre mais c'est fondamental si on
regarde 50 ans en arrière donc c'est
essentiel ça a été vraiment génétique
c'est vrai sur les cellules souches
c'est vrai sur ça va être vrai sur les
neurosciences dans les années qui
viennent on va pouvoir traiter avec les
cellules souches ou avec les organoïdes
des choses tout à fait nouvelles et puis
inversement il y a des progrès de la
science qu'il faut regarder avec
prudence si c'est les cellules souches
pour vous remplacer une hanche ou
remplacer une une un genou très bien si
c'est pour reconstituer des gamètes et
faire de nouveau
avec une gamète artificielle et et faire
un embryon de façon artificielle on est
là sur une ligne rouge donc on voit bien
ça c'est un premier point le deuxième
point c'est que la société bouge vous
avez bougé j'ai bougé
exactement permet des évolutions
sociétales et la société interroge sur
un certain nombre de grandes questions
et le CCNE je dirais à mes yeux mais
c'est la balance c'est pas facile à
trouver tu vois aussi écouter ses
évolutions de la société il doit pas
être hors sol d'où le fait qu'il y a
beaucoup plus de philosophes
non seulement des scientifiques mais des
juristes des philosophes des des
spécialistes de sciences humaines
sociales des citoyens je pose la
question puisque la convention citoyenne
planche sur l'épineuse ou combien
sensibles question de la fin de vie
c'est envisageable ou pas
envisageable c'est déjà la réalité
depuis depuis la loi de bioéthique de
202 nous avons dans le nouveau CCNE si
représentants du milieu associatif et
qui représente et on est 45 membres
voyez si représentants de la société
civile et qui est claire avec en urgence
attendez là vous êtes des intello un peu
compliqué il faut peut-être parler de
façon un tout petit peu plus simple et
donc et ou qui nous font penser encore
un peu plus qu'on ne le faisait à la vie
du citoyen alors s'il y a bien un sujet
qui est l'affaire de tous c'est celui de
la fin de vie je voudrais qu'on revienne
sur la vie du CCNE qui s'est auto saisie
je le précise sur le sujet vous l'avez
rendu en septembre 2022 aujourd'hui il
existe des personnes qui souffrent
d'affection graves incurables dont le
pronostic vital est engagé à moyen terme
je pense évidemment à la maladie de
Charcot qui paralyse les muscles du
corps et qui est terriblement
douloureuse est-ce que ces situations là
ne sont pas couvertes par la loi
Leonetti est-ce que c'est situation là
doivent être prises en compte grâce à
votre avis alors l'avis du CCSE dit
d'abord que la loi classe et honnêtetine
est pas suffisamment connue ni appliquée
elle dit ensuite qu'il faut qu'on
améliore encore les soins palliatifs
pour un médecin un peu âgé comme moi
s'il y a une révolution avec l'arrivée
des soins pénétiques qui font un boulot
extraordinaire c'est c'est la France
n'est pas en retard et même si encore
on reviendra sur la position des
médecins le CCN aussi interrogé en
disant et si on avait tout ça si si tout
marche bien est-ce qu'il n'y a pas en
effet un certain nombre de situations et
donc il reconnaît dans cet avis que un
certain nombre de situations soit de
façon naturelle comme la maladie Sherco
que vous évoquez soit induite par la
médecine c'est-à-dire des des cinquièmes
des sixième ligne de chimiothérapie ou
on est au bout du rouleau de ce que peut
faire la médecine et où il ne faut pas
aller vers une obstination déraisonnable
et donc pose la question
finalement cette question extrêmement
difficile entre autonomie et solidarité
j'entends par autonomie la liberté de
chacun de choisir la forme de son décès
est-ce que notre mort nous appartient ou
est-ce qu'elle appartient finalement à
la médecine ou bien une forme de
solidarité de protéger comme je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure les patients
les plus fragiles et donc de les
protéger entre guillemets et donc le
CCNE a ouvert en effet je dirais poser
la question disons que si la loi évolue
il y a un certain nombre de grandes
respect éthiques qui doivent en faire
un moyen terme et c'est la différence
avec la loi kless Leonetti qui ne
prévoit le court terme c'est à dire quoi
quelques jours de semaine votre avis lui
tiendrait compte des situations où la
mort est inévitable mais à quelques mois
oui alors en sachant que c'est toujours
très difficile de de chiffrer dans ces
périodes mais on voit bien quand même la
différence entre le sec long terme et le
moyen terme quelques semaines à quelques
mois les conventionnels comme on les
surnomme vont rendre leur avis
leur position c'est important que cette
fois-ci il n'y ait pas de comment dire
d'ambiguïté possible ça n'est qu'une
position parmi d'autres et c'est la
représentation nationale qui aura le
dernier mot oui le CSE est recommandé
qui est un grand débat national et le
président de la République nous a suivi
sur sur ce point prendre le temps de
prendre le temps de prendre le temps de
réfléchir donc avec la convention
citoyenne ils vont rendre un certain
nombre de positions à la fin du mois de
mars a été décalé un peu en raison des
événements sociaux et ensuite il
rendront aux autorités en particulier au
président de la République et après
c'est une première étape c'est un grand
débat national nous avons organisé avec
les espaces éthiques régionaux lcse plus
actuellement plus de 320 réunions
régions plus de 35 30 entre 30 5000 et
40000 personnes ont été réunies pour
débuter les gens sont là on voit bien
que c'est des sujets c'est un sujet de
société qui nous intéresse tous qui on
est dans l'humanité l'intime
on est là dans un de quelque chose par
rapport à la discussion de tout à
l'heure de ou la démocratie
participative sur des sujets de ce type
est évidemment un élément fondamental il
nous reste une poignée de seconde les
médecins ils sont très divisés sur le
sujet on a l'impression qu'il y a la
communauté des soins palliatifs qui est
hostile à toute évolution de la loi et
puis il y a une communauté médecin plus
proche de l'Association pour le droit
mourir dans la dignité oui il y a même
une troisième catégorie ce sont les
médecins en général les cancérologues
les spécialistes de neurologie qui sont
partagées je dirais à 55 ans donc il
faut écouter les médecins on ne pour
évoluer il faudra bien sûr tenir compte
de la vie des médecins mais il faut
aussi et c'est quand même ça un des
points essentiels notre notre santé
notre vie n'appartient pas à la médecine
elle appartient à chacun d'entre nous
donc il faut trouver cet équilibre
complexe mais je pense qu'on va y
arriver je pense on a je quand je vois
la qualité des débats qu'il y a en
région ou à l'occasion de la convention
citoyenne je suis optimiste allez vous
restez avec moi je sais que vous nous
direz pas la position du président de la
République qui vous a consulté donc à du
mal à suivre parce que il a il donne le
sentiment parfois de changer d'avis sur
le sujet c'est l'heure de nos affranchis
pour leur partie prix je les invite à
nous rejoindre Carole Barjon ce soir de
l'Obs et puis les haches en Boncelles du
podcast popol bonsoir mesdames bonsoir
on commence avec vous Carole
éditorialiste à lobs vous vouliez
revenir ce soir sur la question
parisienne de de la grève des éboueurs
oui parce que depuis le début de la
semaine lundi nation monte chaque jour
face à la moncellement de
7600 tonnes d'ordures comme à Paris même
s'il y a d'autres villes en France qui
sont touchées et donc il y a
effectivement de quoi s'indigner parce
que c'est un spectacle absolument
intelligent pour l'image de la France
évidemment et c'est une honte sur le
plan sanitaire puisqu’après 10 jours de
grève les rats prolifèrent or face à ce
concert de critique que nous a dit Anne
Hidalgo 1 quelle est la victime du
gouvernement oui oui une victime de quel
soutient la grève des éboueurs et donc
elle ne fera rien qu'elle ne
réquisitionnera pas des personnels comme
liotorisent pourtant le code des
collectivités territoriales il y a une
de ces adjointes qui a affirmé que les
rames sont pas dangereux pour la santé
et notamment pour les enfants oui ça
c'est le pompon on dirait c'est l'exact
contraire de ce que dit l'Académie de
médecine cet adjointe madame Souiris qui
a sans doute une vocation rentrée de
médecins à même expliquer qu'il existait
des vaccins contre la leptospirose or il
faut savoir que les vaccins en question
ne sont destinés qu'à certaines
professions à risque comme précisément
les éboueurs mais en aucun cas aux
enfants pour vous tout est justifié dans
les c'est contre un nid d'algo alors
tout dépend de qui elles émanent dans
cette affaire qu'est-ce qu'on a vu
monter au créneau Gabriel Attal Clément
Beaune Olivier agrégoire et Rachida Dati
pour ne citer que que cela or petit
détail ils sont tous candidats à la
mairie de Paris aux prochaines
municipales autant dire que leur
indignation qui visait bien entendu à
les rendre populaire aux yeux des
Parisiens est assez intéressé Rachida
Dati elle elle est dans son rôle
d'opposante et elle a tapé fort mais les
trois premiers sont ministres à ce titre
ils auraient pu appeler publiquement
leurs collègues ministres de l'Intérieur
à réquisitionner or ils se sont bien
gardés de le faire pourquoi parce qu'il
ne fallait pas prendre le risque
d'énerver les opposants à l'arrêt forme
des retraites avant la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui et le vote au Parlement
demain alors justement les réquisitions
elles sont sur la table Gérald Darmanin
a menacé de réquisitionner les les
éboueurs de la ville de Paris déjà fait
mais on en attendait d'ailleurs pas
moins du ministre de l'intérieur mais
comme par hasard ça menace intervient
deux jours avant la journée fatidique de
jeudi c'est le cours de laquelle sera
votée ou non la réforme des retraits on
en a pas mal débats
il ne faut donc pas être grand clair
pour comprendre qu'il s'agit là d'une
parole d'autorité d'un message en clair
l'ordre doit régner et ce message est
évidemment destiné à séduire les députés
de droite qui hésiteraient encore à
voter la réforme des retraites tout est
utilisé pour obtenir ce vote oui je
comprends vraiment donc c'est une menace
c'est pas un acte la prise de décision
interviendra sans doute vendredi
pourquoi là encore parce qu'il ne
fallait pas risquer d'énerver les
manifestants de ce mercredi bref un peu
d'hypocrisie pour vous oui les arrières
pensées politiciennes ont beaucoup
interféré dans cette affaire on a
assisté au grand bal des hypocrites et
des faux-culs sur le dos des Parisiens
car dans cette affaire c'est quand même
l'intérêt général en l'occurrence la
salubrité publique qui trinque et ben
c'est une carte blanche genre voilà
parti pris signé Carole Barjon il nous
reste allez un peu moins de temps que
d'habitude les haches en Roussel je m'en
excuse d'avance vous vouliez nous parler
ce soir d'un type particulier de ficile
féminicide de féminicite politique
absolument et je voulais d'ailleurs
saluer une initiative qui entend faire
la lumière sur les familles sites
politiques au niveau international
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un féministe
politique il s'agit d'un assassinat
politique genré qui consiste à tuer une
femme non seulement pour la cause
qu'elle défend mais aussi tout
simplement parce qu'il s'agit d'une
femme et si je peux vous en parler ce
soir c'est grâce au collectif de
journalistes youpress qui mène pour la
première fois une enquête internationale
sur les phénicides politiques à travers
d'une part des enquêtes qu'elles ont
menées aux quatre coins du monde mais
aussi la constitution d'une base de
données relative au féminicides
politiques au niveau international cette
base de données nous permet notamment de
d'apprendre que les militants des droits
des femmes ont de loin la quête sont de
loin la catégorie de militante la plus
ciblée par des assassinats sur la
dernière décennie on apprend également
que beaucoup d'entre elles avaient
déposé plainte et grâce aux données
recueillies par le collectif on apprend
que 50% 57% d'entre elles avaient alerté
les autorités de leur pays pour leur
dire qu'elle faisait l'objet de menaces
de mort donc c'est une grande enquête
initiative importante qu'il faut
souligner qui manquait jusqu'à présent
d'ailleurs il manquait terriblement
effectivement et on peut je pense dire
ce soir que il s'agit effectivement d'un
travail véritablement d'utilité publique
puisque les journalistes nous permettent
ainsi de visibiliser des féminicides
totalement occultés de rappeler des
combats oubliés et des vies arrachées
leur travail permet aussi de rappeler la
réalité la violence en fait des attaques
subissent les femmes au quotidien qui se
battent pour les droits humains cyber
harcelés menacé agressé assassinés voici
le lot quotidien des militantes aux
quatre coins du monde c'est en quête
permet enfin de saluer finalement la
mémoire et les combats qui sont menés
par ces militantes mais aussi de
rappeler la fragilité de l'existence des
femmes et des minorités de genre dans un
monde profondément patriarcat et on sur
le le site internet pour en savoir plus
sur cette grande enquête d'un mot pour
terminer le temps nous est compté les
féminicides dans le monde évidemment de
reculer dans le monde ne reculent pas
naturellement ni en France je souhaitais
quand même rappeler qu'à l'heure où nous
parlons on dénombre près de 30
féminicides depuis le 1er janvier soit
tout enfin tous les deux jours donc la
lutte contre les violences bien que ce
soit la grande cause du quinquennat ne
fait pas reculer les féminicides dans
notre pays alerte sur les féminicides
politiques merci beaucoup Léa
chamboncelle Merci à VOUS Jean-François
delfrecy je signale c'est 40 ans de
bioéthique en France chez Odile Jacob
ouvrage que vous avez coordonné avec
Jean-François avec Didier Sicard pas du
tout Emmanuel Didier pardonnez-moi et
Pierre-Henri duet il y a d'autres
anciens présidents qui écrivent de
nombreux articles dans ce livre merci de
nous avoir suivis rendez-vous demain
lors du vérité sur les retraites 19h30
très belle soirée
[Musique]